Barbara Stigler, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle la Sinkerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Oui, je suis professeur de philosophie à
Bordeaux, au département de philosophie
de l'université Bordeaux-Magne.
Voilà. Euh alors, qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait dans ce champ-là ? J'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur un philosophe qui est
Nietzsche sur lequel j'ai écrit deux
livres. Donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé en
philosophie allemande au départ puis je
me suis petit à petit déporté vers la
philosophie politique ce qui était
d'ailleurs mon projet au début et
j'avais mis ça un peu en attente pour
plein de raisons. Je suis allée vers la
philosophie politique dans les dans les
10 dernières années. Voilà.
L'enseignement pourquoi ? Pourquoi la
philosophie luthérienne ? La philosophie
lutherérienne.
Euh la philosophie lutherérienne. J'ai
j'ai travaillé sur Luther à un moment,
mais on va pas dire que c'est mon c'est
ma spécialité centrale. Non, on peut pas
dire ça. L'enseignement, oui,
l'enseignement c'est fondamental dans
mon dans mon travail. Je me vois
difficilement faire ce que je fais sans
enseigner, sans avoir devant moi des
gens vivants à qui
je transmets des choses et qui me
répondent d'autres choses. Voilà.
Si je vous dis ce n'est pas un signe de
bonne santé que d'être bien adapté dans
une société profondément malade.
Je trouve ça très juste.
Je trouve ça très juste comme
objection. Donc c'est c'est pour moi je
sais pas d'où ça vient cette expression,
mais ce qui est drôle c'est que je l'ai
entendu il y a pas longtemps.
Krishna Murti.
Ah oui d'accord. Quelqu'un m' m'en a
parlé. quelqu'un m'a a dû m'envoyer un
message et m'a m'a fait part de cette
citation. [grognement]
Euh
et ça a fait écho à au travail que je
fais actuellement he sur la question de
l'adaptation.
Donc
le le travail que je fais actuellement
tourne autour de ce ce concept
d'adaptation. Est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs un concept ? Plus ou moins,
c'est une idée, une catégorie qui vient
notamment, pas uniquement, mais qui
vient notamment du darwinisme
et qui petit à petit s'est mis à
coloniser, à envahir
le tous les champs de la vie humaine
collective.
Donc, j'ai beaucoup travaillé là-dessus
et euh une ambivalence fondamentale,
c'est effectivement que l'adaptation,
normalement, c'est un signe de bonne
santé. par exemple en psychologie. En
psychologie, c'est un critère
fondamental de la santé psychique,
d'être adapté à son environnement. Et il
y a un moment un peu compliqué où
parfois en s'adaptant ou en se
suradaptant, on est en réalité en train
de s'adapter à quelque chose de
délétaire et donc ce qui était censé
être signe de santé et peut-être signe
de maladie. Donc effectivement quand
j'ai lu cette citation, ça m'a ça a fait
écho à à ce que je fais dans mon
Qu'est-ce que vous trouvez délétaire
dans le l'idéologie du néolibéralisme ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous
fait penser que c'est qu'on va dans le
mur ou que c'est toxique ou
alors beaucoup de choses déjà. Est-ce
que c'est vraiment une idéologie,
une doctrine ? Oui, c'est alors c'est si
c'est une idéologie mais que par
idéologie on entend juste quelque chose
qui relèverait de l'idée et qui n'aurait
pas de réalité, là je serai pas
d'accord. ça va c'est ça va plus loin.
C'est-à-dire que c'est peut-être une
idéologie mais en tout cas ça produit
des effets réels. Ça transforme
réellement les gens et ça a un impact
absolument réel sur les pratiques, sur
les affects enfin voilà c'est quelque
chose de très réel et aussi sur les sur
les corps. Donc c'est plus qu'une
idéologie si on entend par idéologie
quelque chose qui relèverait juste de
représentation mentale figée.
Et alors, rappelez-moi votre question
parce que je l'ai oublié aussitôt.
Qu'est-ce qui vous fait penser que dans
l'idéologie néolibérale
ou
c'est c'est toxique ? C'est délétaire,
c'est c'est contre-productif ?
Alors déjà, j'aimerais bien pour
répondre à votre question vous dire que
je me suis intéressée au néolibéralisme
depuis longtemps [grognement] et euh si
ça m'a intéressé, c'est que je considère
que c'est intéressant.
Et si vous voulez que c'est pas rien du
tout, je viens de le dire à l'instant en
disant que ça ça une ça fait partie du
réel, mais en plus intellectuellement
c'est intéressant et je me doutais que
c'était plus intéressant que ce qu'on
appelait habituellement le
néolibéralisme. Ce qu'on appelle
habituellement le néolibéralisme,
c'est très souvent confondu avec
l'ultralibéralisme, c'est la
dérégulation complète, c'est le retrait
completif
mais de l'État.
C'est euh voilà le déchaînement de
processus marchand,
c'est la financiérisation de l'économie.
C'est ça qu'on appelle souvent le
néolibéralisme.
En réalité euh je sentais bien que ça ne
cadrait pas le néolibéralisme. C'est pas
seulement ça. C'est même peut-être pas
essentiellement ça.
C'est une religion.
Alors euh on peut éventuellement dire
que c'est un rapport avec la religion,
mais euh il y a il y a des liens, il y a
des liens. Mais avant de de de d'en
venir à cet aspect-là, je préfère
répondre à votre question. Euh donc ça
n'est pas l'ultralibéralisme parce qu'en
fait c'est une conception
euh de la vie, de l'humain, du rapport
entre l'humain et l'environnement. Ça,
je le sentais et je le voyais parce que
les politiques néolibérales que j'ai
moi-même éprouvé,
si je puis dire, dans ma chair, dont
j'ai moi-même que j'ai moi-même subi,
par exemple en tant qu'enseignante, en
tant que chercheur à l'université ou
bien dans mon travail avec les
soignants, les médecins, je voyais ces
métiers impactés par des politiques
néolibérales ne correspondaient pas du
tout à la question de la du retrait de
l'État.
Au contraire, il s'agit d'un état,
l'État qui mène une politique
néolibérale, d'un état très invasif qui
intervient constamment dans le champ par
exemple de l'éducation ou de la santé
pour le réformer, le transformer. Donc
c'est un état très présent. Vous voyez
déjà ça c'était contreintuitif. C'est
pour ça que j'ai mené une enquête
historique
pour essayer de comprendre d'où venait
cette affaire. Et ce que j'ai trouvé de
très intéressant quand je me suis
intéressée à la matrice théorique du
néolibéralisme, quand je suis tombée sur
un des auteurs qui est au cœur de la
l'élaboration de cette matrice
théorique, à savoir Walter Lipman qui
est un personnage historique américain
très important euh qui a énormément de
qui a eu un rôle fondamental aux
États-Unis à la fois comme diplomate,
comme journaliste, un des plus grands
chroniqueurs américains qui écrivait
tous les matins une chronique pour pour
ses lecteurs. é extrêmement suivi. Il a
été le conseiller de des grands
présidents et cetera. Ce qui m'a
intéressé, c'est quand je suis allé lire
les les essais théoriques de Lipman,
c'est qu'il posait un problème de
manière assez puissante. Et le problème,
il le posait en terme darwinien et il le
posait en terme d'adaptation. Et ce
qu'il disait en gros, c'est que on doit
repenser complètement la politique à
partir de du choc euh créé par la
révolution darwinienne. On pourra plus
faire de la politique de la même manière
et on pourra plus penser à la politique
de la même manière après Darwin. Darwin
a tout bouleversé. On n plus par exemple
de concept stable et permanent mais tout
est en évolution. Et à partir de là euh
il faut repenser donc euh nous repenser
nous sujet politique comme d'abord les
membres d'une espèce vivante. Cette
espèce vivante est en plongée dans un
environnement et euh l'enjeu pour notre
espèce comme pour n'importe quelle
espèce vivante étant de s'adapter à cet
environnement. Pour l'IPMAN en gros, je
vais un peu vite mais en gros pour
l'ipman, les mécanismes darwiniens
d'adaptation, de sélection, de mutation
et cetera
pour faire perdurer son patrimoine
génétique.
Voilà, pour essayer d'augmenter sa
fitness, c'est-à-dire faire que les
descendants
ben se reproduisent, qu'on ait la
fitness, c'est une un taux de
reproduction le plus en forme possible
hein par rapport au défis de
l'environnement. Euh pour Libman, tout
ça s'est passé correctement, euh plutôt
de bonne manière et les choses étaient
bien orientées jusqu'à une date très
récente pour tous les vivants, y compris
les humains. Il y a eu des mécanismes
darwiniens qui permettaient en gros que
les inaptes soient éliminés, que les
plus aptes soient sélectionnés et c'est
comme ça que on a hérité de la pluralité
des des espèces vivantes avec des des
vivants qui sont plutôt bien ajustés à
leur environnement. Donc tout se passait
en gros pour le mieux. jusqu'à une date
très récente dans l'histoire de la vie.
Pour lui, à partir de la seconde moitié
du 18e siècle
et pour lui Adam Smith a parfaitement vu
cette révolution se produit une
révolution.
Cette révolution, c'est la mise en place
d'un environnement complètement nouveau
dans l'histoire de la vie qui est à
l'échelle du monde, à l'échelle
planétaire euh qui implique une
accélération des rythmes exponentiels
qui implique donc la mise en
une une alors les frontières toutes les
toutes les frontières et les clôtures
sont bouleversées mais d'une manière
extrêmement rapide. Ça c'était le cas
avant hein dans dans le domaine de la
vie. Il avait toujours les
environnements étaient redéfinis avec
les organismes mais là ça va très très
vite. Et on a donc une espèce qui crée
un environnement que lui appelle celui
de la révolution industrielle. Il la
voit des avant le 19e siècle. Il envoie
les signaux dès le la deuxème moitié du
18e siècle, qui est pas entièrement faux
d'ailleurs. Et à partir de là, notre
espèce a donc créé un environnement
complètement nouveau
euh en sans clôture dans lequel toute
forme de stase est menacée et en
accélération donc constante. Et la
grande difficulté pour l'IPman qui est
pas uneintéressante, c'est pas une
inintéressant de poser la question comme
ça, c'est que notre espèce n'est pas
adaptée à ce nouveau monde. Celui qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le monde de la
mondialisation. Nous ne sommes pas
adaptés ni sur le plan cognitif, nous ne
sommes pas équipés sur le plan cognitif,
sur le plan psychique, sur le plan
affectif pour supporter l'environnement
que nous avons nous-mêmes créé. C'est
c'est pour ça qu'on voit la consommation
de psychotropes, la consommation de
drogues, d'anxiolitique augmenté, qu'on
voit des con des conduites addictives de
plus en plus profonde, qu'on voit des
des pratiques de violence y compris de
condu de conduite sexuelle déviante pour
pas lier à ce stress parce que notre
espèce c'est dans un milieu qu'elle
n'est pas capable de gérer, qui lui crée
énormément de stress.
Je dirais que pour diagnostiquer
n'importe quelle maladie, il faut
accepter de il faut accepter qu'il n'y a
pas une cause. Il n'y a pas une cause à
une maladie. ça peut arriver. C'est très
rare. Une maladie, prenons par exemple
le cancer, la plupart du temps, c'est
multicusale. Donc quand on fait des
diagnostics, quand on s'amuse à faire
des diagnostics pour trouver la cause
unique et trouver le coupable pour
ensuite éventuellement l'éradiquer, je
pense qu'on fait fausse route. N'importe
quelle situation pathologique est
multifactorielle.
Ceci dit, je suis assez convaincu, même
si j'ai pas de compétence en
psychiatrie, que le le monde dans lequel
nous vivons, l'environnement industriel
dans lequel nous vivons, alors
industriel, il faut voir ce qu'on entend
par industriel, mais ce que Lipman
appelle industriel à tort ou à raison, à
savoir un monde mondialisé amené à une
accélération des flux, des rythmes
exponentiels de sorte que la division du
travail devienne complètement
mondialisée. Voilà, ce monde là
effectivement crée des troubles
psychiques, c'est évident, ne serait-ce
que dans le rapport au temps.
Est-ce que dans votre étude, vous avez
analysé la rhthorique politicienne, la
conduite politicienne par rapport à
faire passer ce cap, le fameux cap qu'on
doit toujours tenir, quoi qu'il arrive.
Est-ce que vous avez fait émerger des
choses intéressantes là-dessus ?
Alors effectivement, j'entends depuis
toujours, depuis que je suis sur cette
terre euh voilà, je n'ai jamais entendu
d'autres discours dans le discours
politique dominant que nous avons un cap
et il faut nous y tenir. Bon, on l'a
entendu encore récemment, on l'entend en
permanence, c'est une ritournelle. Euh
c'est assez étrange parce que
c'est une ritournel ou c'est une méthode
d'endctrinement ? Alors, c'est aussi une
méthode bien sûr euh qui pose des
problèmes très graves sur le plan de la
démocratie. On en parlera, mais c'est
quand même très étrange puisqu'on est
censé en avoir fini avec toute
conception téléologique de l'histoire.
Euh je m'explique, euh notre temporalité
occidentale a été très longtemps
orientée vers un télos. euh on avait une
temporalité unilinéaire qui allait vers
euh un horizon défini, hein. Euh
évidemment, je pense au christianisme.
Et puis avec ce que Nietzsche a appelé
la mort de Dieu, on aurait pu penser que
on en avait fini avec cette conception
du temps orienté vers une fin, vers un
escaton, vers un but, vers un salut
ultime et que par conséquent, on avait
digéré, accepté, incorporé et digérer le
fait qu'on était dans un que la
temporalité est totalement ouverte et
qu'en fait il n'y a pas de direction
ultime.
Ce que précisément Darwin dit
clairement, penser de manière honnête
l'évolution, c'est accepter l'idée qu'il
n'y a pas de fin de l'évolution et que
l'évolution part dans tous les sens.
C'est ce que nous apprend l'histoire de
la vie. Il n'y a pas de fin de
l'histoire. Or, ce que Nietzsche a très
bien vu, c'est que au moment même de la
mort de Dieu, il y a des philosophies de
l'histoire qui ont pris le relais pour
euh suppléer, si vous voulez, à la crise
de euh de la de la fin pensée, posée,
annoncée, promise par le christianisme
et sa bonne nouvelle. Et c'est donc
toutes les grandes philosophies de
l'histoire qui ont en quelque sorte pris
le relais plus ou moins addroitement,
plus ou moins maladroitement par rapport
à la promesse chrétienne. Voyez donc, il
y a une structure eschatologique qu'on
va retrouver dans la philosophie dans la
dans les grandes philosophies de
l'histoire du 19e siècle et qu'on va
retrouver par exemple pour Nietzsche
dans le marxisme et le socialisme avec
l'horizon révolutionnaire. Bon,
normalement, il est convenu de dire que
on en a fini, c'est ce que disent les
libéraux, la pensée dominante libéral.
Maintenant, au 20e siècle, on est devenu
grand et mur. On en a fini avec ce grand
récit, d'accord ? On en a fini avec ce
grand récit révolutionnaire selon lequel
il y aurait une fin de l'histoire. Donc
le discours dominant politique, c'est de
dire il y a pas de fin de l'histoire,
chacun poursuit ses fins, on est dans
une société multidirectionnelle. Ça
c'est le discours politique dominant des
libéraux et euh le but étant de toujours
ridiculiser
euh et je peux l'entendre d'ailleurs les
espérances révolutionnaires de ceux qui
sont à leur gauche. Sauf que les mêmes
libéraux qui euh donc se gargarisent
d'avoir renoncé à la fin de l'histoire,
à la téléologie et à toutes ces à tous
ses comptes pour enfants, en réalité
vous disent il y a un cap indiscutable,
il y a un sens de l'histoire. Alors, il
il n'ose jamais dire qu'il y a un sens
de l'histoire parce que ça paraîtrait
très naïf, ça paraîtrait de la vieille
métaphysique, hein. Mais en réalité,
c'est ce qu'ils font en répétant sans
cesse. Là, je pense aux droites de
gouvernement, mais aux gauche de
gouvernement aussi, qu'il y a un cap et
que nous sommes obligés de le suivre,
qu'il faut nous adapter à à cela sinon
nous sommes condamnés à à disparaître.
Donc, c'est ça m'a beaucoup frappé.
Nietzsche a tué Dieu. Dieu a tué
Nietzsche
alors Nietzsche a tué Dieu, je ne pense
pas. Et je pense pas d'ailleurs que
Nietzsche aurait pensé qu'il avait tué
Dieu. Enfin, si il y a eu un moment à la
fin de sa vie où il en est arrivé à des
des questions comme ça, bon ça ça l' ça
l'a pas aidé hein. Il y a eu il a eu des
très gros problèmes psychiques au même
moment avant qu'il dise qu'il allait
lui-même tuer Dieu, si je puis dire, et
qu'il était l'antéchrist et cetera, euh
à un autre moment de sa vie où il allait
mieux, il avait une vision peut-être
plus lucide des choses. Dieu est mort.
indépendamment de lui. Nous l'avons tué
depuis très longtemps et ça a pas on n
pas attendu Nietzs pour le faire. Donc
lui, c'est vraiment celui qui a pensé la
mort de Dieu comme comme événement
euh qui nous faut avaler,
qui est très difficile puisque ça nous
plonge par exemple dans un monde de flux
absolu dans lequel il y a plus aucune
forme de permanence, plus aucune
stabilité, plus aucun aucune fin ultime,
plus aucun cap. Donc pour ça, c'est une
pensée qui est très intéressante.
Ça laisse les populations
très perméables
à toute autre idéologie. Est-ce que là
on voit une standardisation de la
pensée, une standardisation des
conduites, une standardisation des
objectifs des des
Alors, effectivement, je pense que c'est
difficile d'accepter l'idée que la
l'évolution n'a pas de direction.
dire que c'est très simple, que oui,
voilà,
la vie part dans tous les sens, on sait
pas où on va pour la vie et pour
l'organisation politique par exemple,
c'est pas facile à endurer. Donc on peut
comprendre qu'on est en vie d'un chef,
d'un cap, d'une tête, de quelque chose,
tout ça marche ensemble lexicalement qui
aille quelque part. Donc la tentation,
par exemple, la tentation est toujours
grande de se recréer une fin de
l'histoire. C'est parce que le l'homme
l'homme tombe dans le misérabilisme de
l'impuissance.
Je ne sais pas. Non, je je Pourquoi vous
dites ça ? Le misérabilisme de
l'impuissance. Non, là je suis vraiment
focalisée sur l'idée que c'est difficile
d'accepter au-delà de la question de la
puissance et de l'impuissance, difficile
d'accepter l'idée qu'on ne sait pas où
l'on va.
En plus, la pensée de Darwin est bien
plus subtile. Elle dit pas qu'on va
n'importe où, dans n'importe quel sens.
Elle dit pas qu'il n'y a aucun sens.
Elle dit qu'il n'y a pas de sens ultime,
mais que quand on étudie en tant
qu'évolutionniste l'histoire de la vie,
il y a des directions.
L'histoire de la vie, c'est pas
n'importe quoi. Ça n'est pas une suite
d'événement sans lien rapodique. Il y a
une il y a une cohérence quand vous
regardez l'apparition d'un organe et
cetera. Voyez, il y a une il y a une
continuité. Donc il y a des directions
en ce sens-là. Il y a du thél mais il
faut l'entendre de manière provisoire,
relative. Voilà, donc il y a pas une fin
ultime, il y a des fins. Donc on a
toujours ce besoin de sens, ce à quoi il
faut et c'est légitime et c'est tout à
fait
précisément compatible avec ce qu'est la
vie. Mais il faut renoncer à l'idée d'un
sens ultime. Et la grande opération du
néolibéralisme,
c'est de trahir le libéralisme classique
en disant il y a une fin de l'histoire
et cette fin de l'histoire, alors c'est
jamais dit comme ça, c'est ce fameux
cap, c'est un monde complètement
mondialisé en accélération constante et
on n pas le choix d'aller dans cette que
d'aller dans une autre direction. C'est
la seule direction possible. première
trahison de du discours affiché par le
libéralisme classique. Je dis pas que
c'était le vrai discours du libéralisme
classique d'ailleurs parce que quand on
regarde de près l'histoire du
libéralisme classique, il y avait
peut-être déjà en fait cette tentation
chez les grands libéraux les passons. Et
puis l'autre grande opération, c'est de
s'appuyer sur la démocratie,
l'utilisation donc de l'outil
démocratique pour forcer mais avec leur
consentement les populations à aller
dans cette direction
et présenter la chose comme de la
démocratie. Ce qui quand même
Oui. En quelque sorte et ce qui quand
même pose problème puisque qu'est-ce que
c'est que l'intérêt de la démocratie ?
L'intérêt fondamental
d'une démocratie, c'est que la
communauté qui compose cette communauté
démocratique
discute ensemble, délibère, s'affronte,
a du conflit sur ce que vous voulez. Si
selon que vous ayez une vision plutôt
conflictuelle de la démocratie ou plutôt
délibérative et consensuelle, peu
importe pour dans ce que je suis en
train de vous dire, l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir une discussion plus ou moins
violente, plus ou moins douce et
consensuelle sur les directions qu'on
veut prendre. Donc à partir du moment où
vous êtes dans un dans une société
démocratique
où la direction n'est pas à discuter, on
peut se demander dans quelle mesure il
s'agit d'une démocratie.
C'est encore faisable d'avoir une
discussion maintenant à l'échelle du
monde avec des superpuissances qui
s'affrontent dans un climat de guerre
économique.
Ça, c'est la question de l'impuissance.
Est-ce qu'il faut un gouvernement
mondial ?
Alors, je ne crois pas la possibilité
d'un gouvernement mondial. J'ai
peut-être complètement tort, mais
spontanément ça me paraît déjà
compliqué. C'est déjà très compliqué.
Les Grecs le disaient, ensuite les
grands philosophes politiques n'ont
cessé de le dire. C'est déjà très
compliqué de penser le gouvernement
d'une communauté d'une communauté ayant
une taille assez importante. Euh un des
grands motifs classique de la pensée
politique, c'est de dire que la
démocratie, elle est bien adaptée, enfin
j'ose pas employer ce terme maintenant
après tout ce que j'en ai dit, mais elle
est bien adaptée à une petite cité comme
Athènes, et encore c'est pas simple,
mais que ça n'est pas pensable pour un
grand pays comme la France, par exemple,
au 18e siècle. Certains vont dire ça,
hein. Certains grands euh grands
penseurs politiques vont dire la
démocratie. Peut-être pour une petite
cité, certainement pas pour un grand
pays. Alors euh on a les mêmes problèmes
avec le gouvernement, hein. Gouverner,
c'est déjà pas simple pour une petite
communauté ou une petite cité. Gouverner
un très grand pays, c'est compliqué.
Gouverner le monde et avoir un
gouvernement central du monde, ça paraît
encore plus fou. Donc je pense de ce
point de vue-là, je sympathise avec les
convictions des libéraux. Je pense queil
faut penser le gouvernement et la
démocratie de manière locale euh et
plurielle, hein. Ça me paraît très
compliqué d'envisager un gouvernement
central. Voilà.
C'est difficile d'avoir une Union
européenne ?
Comment ? déjà très difficile d'avoir
une Union européenne et un gouvernement
de la de de de l'Europe.
On part on part sur le sur l'aspect
politique et de la modification des
corps. Hm.
Euh
est-ce que vous avez vu des des choses
extraordinaires sur le fait que la
politique modifie les êtres
mis à part euh des dépressions, des
obésités, des suicides, des choses comme
ça ?
Oui, je pense effectivement, on en a
parlé tout à l'heure qu'il y a des des
troubles psychiques nouveaux qui sont
liés à une certaine forme de pour parler
comme Michel Fouco de gouvernementalité.
La la force de la gouvernementalité
néolibérale, c'est que les sujets
néolibéraux, moi la première, intègre
intériorise ce mode de
gouvernementalité.
Ça c'est vraiment la force de la chose.
La gouvernementalité néolibérale repose
sur des sujets qui euh loin d'être
passif sont acteurs et euh
se gouverne même sur ce mode-là. Voilà.
Donc ça modifie par exemple, je le
disais tout à l'heure, le rapport au
temps. Là, il devient très difficile euh
d'être lent par exemple, ça devient très
compliqué. Ou alors, on accepte d'être
lent de manière intermittente,
c'est-à-dire que on va par exemple avoir
des rythmes de plus en plus accélérés et
on va se ménager dans des un peu comme
avec le sommeil, des des espaces
particuliers dans lesquels on va avoir
des disciplines physiques où on aura le
droit d'être lent.
un peu comme ici
par exemple, pendant 1 heure, on aura le
droit d'être lent deux fois par semaine
pour pouvoir être encore plus rapide
ensuite. Et c'est là qu'on voit comment
le monde néolibéral peut éventuellement
s'appuyer de manière très
euh très productive sur toutes les
nouvelles techniques de corporel de
méditation. Non, je pense à la
méditation, à toutes les techniques,
vous savez, qu'on peut pratiquer pour
être encore plus efficace quand on en a
fini avec la méditation. Voyez ce que je
veux dire ?
Vous avez côtoyé la classe un peu.
Est-ce que vous avez côtoyé la upper
class politique ?
Non, pas du tout.
Pas du tout.
Non.
Donc vous avez pas vu si ils avaient des
pathologies inérentes au stress dû à
l'accélération des flux.
Non, j'ai j'ai pas eu l'occasion en fait
de de rencontrer des personnellement
des des du personnel politique. C'est
vraiment un univers que je ne connais
pas.
mais qui mais qui m'intéresse hein. Mais
voilà, je suis très déconnectée de de
cet univers là.
C'est pas plus mal hein. Des fois, ils
sont un peu toxiques, non ? Euh, je vais
vous poser une question internet. La
première qui me vient devant les yeux.
Avez-vous travaillé sur Edward Bern
Berneys pardon,
neveu de freud des héritiers de Lipman
dans la propagande néolibérale ? Il a
écrit un très bon bouquin qui s'appelle
Propaganda.
Ouais.
Donc non, je n'ai pas travaillé
directement sur Bernz, mais c'est
effectivement très important parce que
Bernz en fait est un grand lecteur de
Lipman
et donc il va s'intéresser de très près.
Il va être vraiment il est fasciné Bernz
par la théorie lipmanienne de la
manufacture du consentement. Voilàki
Chomski s'était attardé dessus. Non
Chomski s'est beaucoup intéressé à
Lipman
pour cette raison pour ce pour ce pour
ce travail. La manufacture du
consentement, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est l'idée euh donc c'est la reprise
d'un motif classique de la philosophie
politique, vraiment un sujet tout à fait
classique de philosophie politique,
c'est le consentement. Ça s'impose au
17e siècle
comme une nécessité. On ne peut pas
passer un pacte social, enfin le pacte
social
implique le consentement. Le
consentement est
ou la soumission.
Comment
ou la soumission ? L'idée c'est
justement d'éviter la soumission,
d'éviter l'intimidation, d'éviter la
violence, d'éviter l'état violent et de
refonder l'État sur d'autres base. Alors
ça peut plus être Dieu. Donc on est dans
on entre dans la modernité, ça peut plus
être une base théologique. On a affaire
à des vivants. Euh voilà, il y a plus
cette fondation là. C'estant déjà le le
thème de la mort de Dieu. Il faut
repenser donc le pacte, il faut repenser
l'État et sa nécessité sur d'autres
bases. Et l'idée c'est donc d'éviter que
ce soit la violence qui fonde la chose.
Et euh donc on a toutes sortes de
théories politiques classiques qui vont
fonder le pacte social sur beaucoup de
choses mais notamment sur le
consentement.
Euh donc l'idée centrale et ça c'est
c'est aujourd'hui encore très très
puissant. Par exemple, vous l'avez vous
avez le modèle du consentement qui s'est
imposé dans le monde de la santé. Pour
éviter que le rapport entre patient et
euh pouvoir médical soit un rapport
d'asymétrie potentiellement violent,
l'idée c'est qu'on demande son
consentement au patient. Bon, ça vient
vraiment de la philosophie politique
classique.
Le consentement dans la conception
classique, il se recueille
par les urnes.
Par les urnes, par exemple, mais pas
uniquement. Ça peut être
quels sont les vecteurs de de
consentement ?
Alors, juste finir là-dessus, il se
recueille. Ça veut donc dire qu'il vous
appartient. Si euh je vous si je
recueille votre consentement, ça veut
dire que c'est le c'est le vôtre et donc
je n'ai pas à l'avoir fait. Vous
comprenez ? Libman prend totalement le
contrepied. Donc c'est extrêmement
provocateur, c'est une rupture très
violente en disant "On peut plus faire
comme ça parce qu'on a affaire à des
masses totalement atomisées qui partent
dans tous les sens, qui savent pas ce
qu'elles veulent. Elles ne sont pas
équipées psychiquement, affectivement,
cognitivement, culturellement.
Pour dire ça, pour vous dire ça plus
simplement, c'est c'est des masses,
c'est c'est des cons
euh
Non, pas pour Lipman.
Non, c'est autre chose que la question
de la bêtise. C'est
c'est du genre petite bête.
Non, pour lui ça dépasse la question
morale de ceux qui sont bêtes et ceux
qui pour lui c'est nous sommes pour lui
[grognement] des sociétés massifiées.
Il réfléchit un peu comme Gill Legendre.
Non, non plus. C'est qui dit qu'il a il
a été trop intelligent ? Non, ça c'est
vraiment vulgaire. Gill le gendre. et le
le l'extrait auquel vous faites
allusion, nous avons été trop
intelligents et cetera, c'est très
vulgaire et ça serait un peu insulter la
pensée de l'iman qui est beaucoup plus
subtile. L'idée c'est nous sommes nous
composons tous des sociétés de masse.
C'està-dire par exemple moi Walter
Lipman, je suis quelqu'un de très
intelligent. Je pense qu'il s'estimé
quelqu'un d'être très intelligent.
[grognement] Il était très content de
lui mais que il savait très bien que
politiquement il faisait partie d'une
masse. Et à ce titre, voyez, c'est autre
chose que la question de est-ce que X
était intelligent ? Voilà. Alors,
j'étais en train de vous dire que donc
on ne veut plus à partir du moment où on
n plus par exemple une communauté de
citoyens athéniens devant nous, mais
qu'on a des masses comme la masse des
Américains, on ne peut plus pour l'imman
raconter qu'on va recueillir ce
consentement. Il y a rien à recueillir.
Il y a des individus atomisés, épuisés,
qui poursuivent leurs propres intérêts
étroits et personnels et il y a aucun
recueil possible du consentement. Donc
que faire ? Il faut fabriquer le
consentement par des techniques. Or, il
y a à l'époque où l'iman pense cela des
gens qui le font de manière
redoutablement efficace. Par exemple,
Benito Mussolini le fait avec les les
nazis ensuite et avec le cinéma, des
techniques de communication et cetera et
cetera. Donc pour l'imman, on n pas le
choix. Il faut assumer le fait que on
doit fabriquer artificiellement et
d'ailleurs avec des techniques
industriel à l'échelle industrielle le
consentement des masses. On n pas le
choix. Et si nous ne le faisons pas,
dit-il, c'est eux qui le feront. eux,
c'est-à-dire d'abord les fascistes puis
les nazis et qui mèneront les masses et
qui nous mèneront à la catastrophe
puisque l'idée sera par exemple de
sera par exemple de de de rendre
possible la domination d'une prétendue
race arienne, ce qui pour Lipman est une
absurdité totale puisqu'il n'y a même
pas de race race. L'idée qu'il y aurait
une race pure germanique pour lui est
une pure absurdité puisque il n'y a plus
d'essence éternelle. Toute idée de
entité pure qui serait au-delà du
devenir n'existe pas. Tout est en flux.
Donc le racisme est une absurdité
totalement archaïque. Donc si on laisse
faire, voilà ce qu'on aura. On aura
autre autre risque le déchaînement de
nationalisme, c'est-à-dire de nations,
par exemple l'Italie qui vont vouloir
écrabouiller toutes toutes les autres
nations. On on va à la catastrophe. Donc
la seule solution, c'est d'assumer
les techniques de propagande. Il il ose
en parler, il parle dans ces termes. Et
il faut que ce soit une propagande
orienté dans la bonne direction,
c'est-à-dire celle d'une rendant
possible l'adaptation
des masses à aux exigences de la
mondialisation.
Vous avez un regard critique sur en
train sur ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment sur le consentement
des masses. Est-ce que la République en
marche et notre notre président Emmanuel
Macron,
est-ce qu'ils ont pas un peu failli
dans leur capacité à
nous emmener vers leur idéologie ?
Ça se passe très mal pour eux. Euh je
crois qu'ils le savent.
Euh ça se passe très très mal. Oui, pour
la République en marche, c'est ça doit
être dur pour eux parce que ça se
passait plutôt bien pour tous les autres
avant.
Donc ça doit vraiment être très
douloureux. Oui.
Vous expliquer qu'il se soit fait euh
ravager dans leur capacité à faire le
consentement des masses. Ils sont trop
ils sont trop intelligents, ils sont ils
sont trop rapides,
ils sont trop respectueux, ils sont quoi
?
Non, je pense qu'ils tombent au mauvais
moment. C'est-à-dire que il y a pour moi
un élément central d'explication, c'est
la crise environnementale qu'on
l'appelle comme ça, la crise écologique.
Avant la crise énergétique
hein.
Avant la crise énergétique,
comment ça avant
le premier choc pétrolier ? Ça les a un
peu tendu. L'augmentation du prix du
baril, ça les a un peu tendu. Ça ça a
limité leur impact dans la capacité.
Je comprends ce que voulez dire. Non, en
fait, j'appelle, c'est bien parce que ça
me permet de préciser, j'appelle crise
écologique, non pas le désastre
écologique que nous avons nous-mêmes
créé avec la révolution industrielle
depuis fort longtemps.
Vous vous expliquez ça parce que il
butent sur les fondamentaux.
Non, j'appelle crise écologique le sens
c'est le sens en fait utilisé
actuellement. La crise écologique, c'est
non seulement le fait qu'objectivement
la planète soit en voie d'être de
destruction et cetera. Et ça ça fait
très longtemps. Mais le fait que tout le
monde en ait pris conscience et ça ça
fait très peu de temps. Si vous voulez
prenons les années 70 dans les années 70
c'était une minorité de gens qui
pensaient que l'écologie c'était un vrai
problème. Évidemment c'est les les les
les grands mouvements écologistes des
années 70 étaient puissants, forts et
cetera, mais ils étaient minoritaires.
Ils restaient quand même à la marge de
la société. Euh ce qui est nouveau à
partir de euh
quand on entre dans le 21e siècle, il y
a une série de de de chocs, de prise de
conscience et cetera qui font que
à peu près tout le monde sur cette terre
est à peu est au courant et sait que il
y a une crise environnementale. C'est ça
que j'appelle la crise environnementale.
C'est la crise environnementale non
seulement objectivement mais dans les
consciences. Et euh c'est ça qui euh
compliquer les choses subordnation de
vote.
Comment
ce qui va compliquer la subordination de
vote ?
Ce qui va compliquer la tâche à au
mouvement qui est au pouvoir
actuellement, c'est ça. Mais vous allez
me dire c'est absurde puisqu'on est en
2019 et moi je situe le moment où
vraiment tout le monde commence à
prendre conscience y compris les plus
grands décideurs, y compris tout ce que
vous voulez. Tout le monde prend
conscience de la crise environnementale,
on va dire juste après 2000, autour de
2005, quelque chose comme ça dans le
monde entier.
Euh le donc c'est pas logique parce que
on est en 2019 et les choses se
passaient plutôt bien au niveau du
consentement pour les gouvernement
précédent. Il y a pas eu de crise du
consentement comme il on en a comme on
en a aujourd'hui même s'il y avait ce
qu'on appelle la crise du politique.
Mais juste je finis juste juste
là-dessus. Pourquoi ils ont failli ?
Pourquoi par exemple ils s'exposent à
des à un échec politique enfin il
mettent en il y a une crise politique
beaucoup plus grave que sous François
Hollande ? Et bien parce qu'ils ont le
mérite effectivement
de d'exprimer le néolibéralisme. Ce que
faisait Hollande aussi he Hollande était
la politique de
c'est la finance la
mais la politique de Hollande était
foncièrement néolibérale et je pourrais
vous le montrer dans le détail mais et
d'ailleurs c'est lui-même qui a qui
avait comme conseiller Emmanuel Macron.
C'est lui qui l'a choisi. Il l'a
énormément suivi et Emmanuel Macron est
au pouvoir depuis des années en réalité.
Donc, mais pourquoi ça a fonctionné ?
Parce qu'en fait, c'était un peu plus
enrobé dans de la social-démocratie.
C'était un peu moins, si vous voulez
pur. Là, avec le avec Emmanuel Macron,
on a une expression euh vraiment presque
chimiquement pure de la matrice
théorique néolibérale et c'est tellement
spectaculaire qu'évidemment ça se
évidemment c'est plus compliqué.
J'ajoute une, si je peux me permettre,
j'ajoute à votre prisme de lecture
l'augmentation du prix du baril de
pétrole.
Regardez bien l'augmentation du prix du
baril de pétrole. Ça leur laisse quand
même d'énormes séquelles dans leur
capacité à subordner le vote,
à prendre le contrôle du du
consentement.
Bon, parenthèse fermée. Autre question
d'internet.
Est-ce que le récit technologique est le
nouveau récit de l'humanité avec le
transhumanisme par exemple ? Alors, je
sais pas ce qu'on appelle ce que le
l'auteur de ce message appelle le récit
technologique.
La science va nous sauver, on va trouver
des nouvelles techniques, on va nettoyer
la terre, on va s'augmenter le cerveau,
on va donner la à la capacité de la
petite couturière,
la capacité d'Instein avec une petite
puce dans son cerveau, des choses comme
ça. Cette nouvelle idée,
la rhtorique de la promesse,
pas mal, pas mal. C'est c'est un peu ça.
Bon, ça c'est la rhtorique de la
promesse.
Diversion.
La rhtorique de la promesse, c'est
quelque chose qui a été beaucoup étudié
par les sociologues sociologues des
sciences qui montre que les sciences
actuellement fonctionnent dans un
environnement extrêmement compétitif. En
fait, si vous voulez, quand vous êtes
chercheur en science, vous passez
beaucoup de temps à travailler sur vos
éprouvettes et cetera, mais vous passez
peut-être plus de temps, je suis à la
limite de la du caricatural, à chercher
des fonds et à récupérer des
financements, ce qui quand même être un
peu étrange puisque ça peut être un peu
énervant quand on veut être chimiste,
biologiste ou philosophe de passer la
moitié de son temps à chercher des sous
pour dire les choses. Et donc on a un
modèle de la recherche qui est mondial
pas du tout spécifique à la France où
les les les chercheurs sont mis en
compétition en permanence pour inventer
des projets innovants et cetera et et
recueillir des fonds. Donc cette cette
chose-là a favorisé ce qu'on appelle euh
la rhtorique de la promesse.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous avez l'envie
de développer quelque chose parce que
vous dites c'est potentiellement
intéressant, vous êtes obligé de de
déposer un dossier dans lequel vous
dites c'est ça qui va sauver par exemple
les malades. Alors même qu'on en sait
rien puisqu'on a pas commencé à
chercher. Vous avez ça par exemple avec
la médecine personnalisée. La médecine
personnalisée qui est très très très
puissante et qui en même temps est très
faible puisque elle elle ne remplit pas
totalement ses promesses. C'est moins
qu'on puisse dire. la médecine
personnalisée fondée sur les big data
sur voilà sur tout ça je pense que vos
auditeurs situent à peu près cette
médecine personnalisée elle fonctionne
complètement sur la base de cette
rhtorique de la promesse.
Est-ce qu'on peut revenir sur est-ce
qu'on peut délayer
l'arsenal
que la her class ou que la la classe
politique utilise pour le consentement
des masses ?
Quel est l'arsenal ?
Ouais. Est-ce qu'on peut délayer cet
arsenal ? Je pense que c'est ça
qu'est-ce que vous appelez délayer
qu'on peut euh
rentrer un peu plus dans le détail
détaillé
détaillé détaillé. Ouais. Alors moi je
je connais pas très très bien les
techniques de consentement actuel. J'ai
j'ai je voilà je vous regarde ça un peu
de loin. J'ai pas forcément les
compétences pour vous le dire. Par
contre ce qui m'intéresse
bridge Analytica, ça vous parle pas ?
Non, mais par exemple ce qui moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment ça a été
théorisé par Lipman parce que c'est
c'est vraiment tout à fait ce qu'il a
fait et pour lui euh donc il faut
fabriquer, je disais ce consentement et
pour lui il y a des ressources euh en
gros il y a deux continents fondamentaux
pour l'arsenal parce que c'est vraiment
un arsenal pour lui c'est un arsenal
d'ailleurs thérapeutique hein parce que
le but c'est il est il est bienfaisant
il se pense bienfaisant c'est pour bien
faire c'est pour nous sauver hein sinon
on va disparaître donc le but c'est
vraiment une une question de survie pour
lui hein. Donc il pour lui cet arsenal
thérapeutique pour éviter ben le
fascisme, le nazisme, le fait qu'on soit
balayé et qu'on soit incapable de nous
réadapter à notre environnement qui est,
je l'ai dis, celui de la mondialisation,
c'est euh deux il y a deux types de
ressources. Il y a d'une part évidemment
les médias, mais alors les médias au
sens très large du mot, les médias, ce
qu'on appelle couramment les médias,
mais aussi euh si vous voulez les la le
cinéma, toutes les formes de médiation
technique qui permettent de délivrer euh
des messages. Premier premier grand
continent dont la politique doit
s'emparer pour fabriquer le consentement
des masses. Et le deuxième grand
continent, et pour lui ça c'est
fondamental, ce sont les sciences
humaines et sociales, c'est-à-dire ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui et ce qu'il
appelle lui déjà les experts.
Les experts, c'est c'est une figure
nouvelle he qui s'est imposée au 20e
siècle, l'expertise. Euh c'est tous ce
sont tous ces chercheurs spécialisés.
Euh il y a pas d'expert sans hypers
spécialisation. un expert est quelqu'un
qui est hyper spécialisé, qui a une
connaissance pointue et cette euh
ces experts en sciences humaines et
sociales sont fondamentaux. Alors, il
faut des experts en sciences évidemment,
par exemple en sciences de
l'environnement évidemment hein, bien
sûr, mais il faut aussi des experts en
sciences humaines et sociales pour
arriver à prendre en main ces
populations. sociologue évidemment,
géographe bien sûr, mais aussi et
surtout les plus les experts les plus
important pour l'iman, les psychologues,
ceux qui ont une connaissance de des
mécanismes psychiques
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
fabriquer le consentement. Encore
faut-il pour fabriquer le consentement
des masses, encore faut-il avoir des
notions pour l'hypman de psychologie
sociale, de savoir comment se comportent
les masses ou ce qu'on appelait avant
les foules. Il faut avoir une
compréhension de tout ça. Donc en gros,
il faut une connaissance très
approfondie des médiation
technologiques, des médias au sens très
large du mot et des sciences de de
l'humain, les sciences de cette espèce
particulière qui est l'espèce humaine,
en particulier du psychisme mais aussi
de tout ce qui relève du social. Si je
vous dis à ces foules aveugles ou à ces
politiques qui leur crèvent les yeux, ça
vous fait penser à quoi ? Je vois pas
très bien.
Si je vous dis Gustave Lebon.
Alors bien sûr, je pensais à lui, je
pensais à Gabriel Tard et Gustave Lebon
parce que la question des foules et
cetera. Mais chez Libman c'est encore un
autre une autre étape, c'est un peu plus
tardif et c'est vraiment le concept
opératoire, c'est le concept de masse
qui d'ailleurs qu'il n'a évidemment pas
inventé dont il a hérité du 19e siècle.
Voilà. Et donc là, il a une
compréhension très très fine, enfin fine
qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut, mais disons
très précise, très détaillée de la masse
dont il est parfaitement conscient, je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure, de faire
lui-même partie, hein. Bon, euh dont
nous faisons pour lui tous partie.
[grognement]
Euh et cette masse, en gros, ce qu'il a
défini pour lui, c'est qu'elle est euh
apathique.
Alors, apathique, ça veut dire qu'elle
ne se sent pas elle-même. C'est la c'est
pour vous expliquer les choses, c'est
complètement le contraire de la la
classe avec la conscience de classe. Une
classe, hein, pour les marxistes, ce qui
est fondamental, c'est qu'il y a une
conscience de classe. La masse n'a pas
de conscience d'elle-même. Donc ça veut
dire que chaque individu qui compose la
masse est enfermé en lui-même avec son
petit cercle. Donc elle est apathique.
Ça veut donc dire qu'elle est atomisée.
C'est-à-dire que ce qui compose la
masse, c'est une c'est une accumulation
énorme d'atomes d'atomes individuels.
Est-ce que imaginez-vous qu'on leur
donne maintenant, on est au 21e siècle,
on leur donne pour théoriser leur
capacité à modéliser les masses, on leur
donne Facebook,
la big data, des des des fuites de
données.
On leur donne à qui ?
À aux philosophes ou aux politiques ? on
leur donne ou du moins ils le prennent.
H
pour modéliser cette masse atomisée euh
qui a plus du tout conscience de sa
classe.
Il est vraiment tout à fait évident que
pour Lipman, enfin Lipman a tout mis en
place dans sa conception des choses pour
s'emparer immédiatement de ce genre de
choses. Ça c'est pour ça aurait été pour
lui mais je pense qu'il l'avait même
déjà anticipé une ressource
fondamentale. Il savait très bien que le
tous ces systèmes techniques étaient en
train de se développer. Je pense que
pour lui je je suis pas tombée sur une
ligne de lui là-dessus mais ça doit
exister. il devait forcément voir que
quelque chose comme des réseaux sociaux
avec les machines qui étaient en train
de s'inventer aller s'établir il aurait
pas du tout été surpris et donc il se
serait euh enfin ça sa pensée lui permet
de s'emparer immédiatement de ce genre
de chos. Le but c'est ça.
Vous pensez que les politiques se sont
emparés de cette
pensée de cette technique de
modélisation ?
Ça reste quand même très archaïque.
C'est-à-dire que voilà, il y a déjà dans
la manière dont leur rapport au sondage,
c'est tellement peu efficient, je
trouve. C'est tellement à courte vue que
je non, je suis pas je suis pas je ne
suis pas fascinée par la manière dont
les politiques actuelles de manière
extrêmement fine et puissante et
opératoire se serait emparé. Non, pas
vraiment.
Technologies prédictive, ça vous parle ?
Oui, forcément parce que c'est les big
data, il y a aussi cet enjeu-là, hein,
de de profiler euh les cop
comment
palentir
non.
Cambridge Jalintica
non, vous m'avez déjà demandé, je vous
dis je vous ai dit.
Autre question internet, euh je prends
la première qui arrive. Macron implique
donc la doctrine de Lipman en présentant
LROM comme la seule alternative à
l'extrême droite.
Effectivement, il y a il y a un écho
assez saisissant. C'est-à-dire que pour
l'imag, il y a deux voies, on l'a dit,
soit l'adaptation à la mondialisation à
un monde ouvert, prétendument sans
frontière et cetera, soit le repli
nationaliste, le déchaînement du
racisme, la xénophobie et ceci étant du
côté de l'archaïsme et et de et on va
directement dans le mur. Donc c'est il y
a il y a que ces deux possibilités. Le
reste, les deux sont puissantes et
réelles. Le reste pour lui c'est des
comptes pour enfants. Voilà. Et donc on
a exactement la même structuration
aujourd'hui avec d'un côté mais ça
dépasse totalement la personne de
d'Emmanuel Macron. C'est quelque chose
beaucoup plus large et il n'a rien
inventé. Le populisme, ce qu'on appelle
le populisme qui à mon avis, je suis pas
le seul la seule à le penser, est une
catégorie tout à fait contestable et de
l'autre côté l'adaptation à la
mondialisation, les libéraux.
Donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est mis
en place. C'est une petite musique qu'on
entend depuis des années et qui rejoue
effectivement
le manikéisme de Lipman.
Autre question d'internet. Comment se
désintoxiquer du libéralisme et du
rapport au temps par exemple ?
Ouais, c'est une vraie question parce
qu'en réalité c'est assez addictif.
C'est-à-dire que quand on se met à
entrer dans cette euh dans à avoir cette
vie euh adaptée à la mondialisation et
on a des ressources extraordinaires
d'adaptation, enfin je le vois en
moi-même, je vois bien que je j'arrive à
tenir le choc, à euh prendre plein
d'avion, partir dans tous les sens,
avoir une vision d'un monde complètement
enfin le plus ouvert possible en
accélérant nos rythmes psychiques, en
accélérant nos rythmes de vie, en
accélérant nos rythmes familiaux et
cetera. C'est donc à la fois évidemment
ça nous fait souffrir à moins d'être
vraiment des gens très étranges. Donc
c'est bon ces gens très bien adaptés qui
on réité serait malade. Si on est un peu
sain, ça nous fait souffrir mais en même
temps c'est assez jubilatoire. Donc
c'est très très difficile de se
désintoxiquer de cette manière de vivre
quand on y a goûté.
Autre question internet. Vous avez lu
l'entraide de Cropotkin qui parle de
l'entraide non naturel comme l'élément
essentiel de l'évolution.
Malheureusement, j'ai jamais travaillé
encore, mais je vais être vraiment
obligé de le faire. Ça fait partie des
livres à lire sur
l'entraide, excusez-moi. [rires]
Et et c'est très important parce que ça
fait partie des alternatives.
Euh, il y en a plein d'autres, il y a
plein d'auteurs comme ça qui sont en
fait du côté des alternatives de la
pensée environnementale, de l'écologie.
ben tout ce qui est reprise du
darwinisme sur d'autres bases,
c'est-à-dire pas la base de la
compétition,
de l'égoïsme et cetera, mais repartir de
la pensée du vivant, de la pensée
darwinienne pour dire qu'en réalité dans
le vivant, il y a des mécanismes euh qui
tout autre enfin le mécanisme mécanisme
d'ailleurs pas du tout la bonne
expression, il y a des euh processus qui
sont pas du tout basés sur la
compétition entre individus mais qui
sont basés sur la coopération entre
individus et la coopération entre
groupes. Et en réalité, donc c'est pour
ça que tout tous ces auteurs-là sont
très importants. Et en réalité dans le
darwinisme contemporain, c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce qui est établi, c'est que le
modèle darwinien classique
orthodoxe à lui-même c'est lui-même
révisé et en réalité, il y a toutes
sortes de de processus de coopération.
En fait,
questionnet. Euh
est-ce que la compétition est une valeur
forte du libéralisme ? Oui.
Est-ce que l'existence d'une culture
officielle est une manière de
Attendez, je veux bien répondre à cette
question.
Allez
sur
On vous autorise
parce qu'effectivement, je l'ai dit
moi-même là à l'instant, le libéralisme
va aller chercher dans le darwinisme
l'idée que on a des individus en
compétition les uns avec les autres et
on va valoriser ce ce ce modèle là. En
réalité, c'est plus compliqué. En
réalité euh
le libéralisme
et le néolibéralisme ont à la fois un
discours sur la compétition et un
discours sur la coopération.
C'est-à-dire que l'idée générale, c'est
que il faut mettre tous les individus en
compétition au maximum pour que les
meilleurs comportements et cetera soient
sélectionnés. D'accord ?
Ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
maintenant. Alors ça c'est une autre
question mais le but c'est que ces
mécanismes compétitifs créent de la
coopération. Celui qui a vraiment
théorisé ça, c'est Herbert Spencer, donc
bien avant le néolibéralisme, à la fin
du 19e siècle, qui a euh posé que les
mécanismes compétitifs étaient en train
de créer une grande société mondialisée
intégrée dans lesquelles tous les
rouages
euh étaient parfaitement ajustés les uns
aux autres et que l'horizon, le Télos,
la fin de l'histoire, c'était cette
grande société mondialisée de complète
coopération. En d'autres termes, pour
Herbert Spencer, les mécanismes
compétitifs sont indispensables
nécessaires mais provisoires. Ils ils
sont imparfaits et ils seront
progressivement pour lui de plus en plus
dépassés par une grande coopération
mondiale dans laquelle il n'y aura plus
de conflit.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros la Terre pour
lui fonctionnera à l'issue quand le
capitalisme mondialisé se sera
véritablement installé et [grognement]
qu'il n'aura plus
été perturbé par des choses archaïques
comme l'État.
quand voilà quand les mécanismes auront
pu se déployer, la la le capitalisme
mondialisé sera un ensemble dans lequel
tous les individus coopent les uns avec
les autres de manière parfaitement
ajustée et dans lequelle il n'y a plus
ni de guerre ni même de conflit.
Donc il y a un discours des du
libéralisme, de l'ultralibéralisme,
des libéraux en général et des
néolibéraux non seulement pour valoriser
la compétition mais aussi pour valoriser
la coopération. Donc c'est pas parce
qu'on parle de coopération et qu'on sort
le terme de coopération ou même
d'entraide comme une sorte de mantra que
on a régler le problème. C'estàd que
c'est beaucoup plus subtile que ça.
Là là à l'heure actuelle on sélectionne
les plus cupides, les ceux capables de
marcher le plus rapidement sur les têtes
des autres, d'écraser les autres.
Ça c'est une très très importante
question.
Et et et ensuite je suis désolé de dire
ça mais les femmes sélectionnent les
plus les plus durs d'entre nous. Donc ma
question c'est est-ce que le monde ira
mieux quand les femmes sélectionneront
les les hommes
Alors si vous voulez m'entraîner sur la
question de la sélection sexuelle. La
sélection sexuelle c'est ce qui a été
théorisé Darwin qui a un autre mécanisme
sélectif que la sélection autre paradis
tout le to
Oui. C'est parce qu'il a dit que la
sélection naturelle ça expliquait
beaucoup de choses mais pas tout. Il a
été obligé de chercher d'autres
mécanismes et il a et enfin mécanisme
n'est pas le mot mais de compléter sa
théorie par d'autres modes de sélection.
Et il y a une théorie d'arignan
extrêmement compliquée et extrêmement
intéressante sur la sélection sexuelle.
Après, le passage de la sélection
sexuelle chez les animaux, les plantes,
les animaux à l'espèce humaine est très
périlleux et euh je vais pas ici là euh
l'improviser. On a tout le temps,
même si euh je j'aurais bien aimé vous
faire plaisir, mais je ne le ferai pas.
Donc ça c'est pas possible. Euh en
revanche, votre première non pas
question mais objection est très
importante à savoir en gros voilà ce que
j'entends dans votre question,
c'est-à-dire j'entends une objection. En
gros, c'est vous nous dites que le
néolibéralisme, c'est l'idée de
sélectionner par le rôle de l'État, un
état qui va être vraiment qui va
intervenir, sélectionner les plus aptes
pour parvenir à une compétition assez
fairplay et cetera. C'est ça que je dis
effectivement et que c'est une pensée,
vous nous dites que c'est une pensée
hégémonique, dominante et cetera. Mais
alors comment vous pouvez dire ça alors
même qu'on a affaire non pas quand on
regarde le monde tel qu'il est à à cela,
à cette compétition loyale fairplay qui
soi-disant sélectionnerait les plus
aptes, mais qu'on a affaire à un
ultralibéralisme complètement brutal
avec des mécanismes de prédation où les
plus gros écrabouillent les plus
vulnérables. Et vous avez parfaitement
raison. C'est-à-dire que moi je ne pense
pas du tout en décrivant le
néolibéralisme décrire
le l'alpha et l'oméga du réel. dire, je
suis convaincu que le réel est beaucoup
plus embrouillé que toute approche
théorique du réel. On le néolibéralisme,
c'est quelque chose de très important,
c'est une voie d'entrée fondamentale.
Euh mais dans la réalité, les choses
s'hybrident entre ultralibéralisme et
néolibéralisme par exemple.
Pour vous dire les choses autrement,
quand on regarde la réalité de la
France, de ce qui se passe en France
politiquement, c'est un mélange et même
de ce qui se passe au niveau
gouvernemental actuellement, c'est un
mélange de néolibéralisme au sens le
plus pur, mais en réalité cette pureté
elle existe pas vraiment parce qu'elle
se mélange avec de l'ultralibéralisme
parfaitement classique et très
archaïque. exemple la manière dont le
pouvoir actuel a réactivé la théorie du
ruissellement. La théorie du
ruissellement, c'est pas du tout une
théorie néolibérale. Les néolibéraux
qui sont qui se qui ont surgi à la suite
de la crise de 29
sont nés contre les illusions de la
théorie du ruissellement. le
ruissellement ne marchait pas puisque le
capitalisme à la fin du 19e siècle et du
20e siècle est un capitalisme de
prédation qui a conduit à des monopoles
monstrueux euh et cetera, a conduit à
une catastrophe économique, sociale et
politique. Donc les nouveaux libéraux
qui vont penser le néolibéralisme autour
de Lipman et avec lui vont vouloir
rompre avec cet ultralibéralisme de
capitalisme de prédation et en partie
lui ils vont faire une critique de
l'accumulation des rentes, de
l'accumulation des monopoles et des
privilè et ils vont dire
héritage aussi
et ils vont dire que cette accumulation
est quelque chose de de de qui ne va pas
dans le sens de l'histoire puisque
l'histoire euh le sens de l'histoire
c'est d'aller vers toujours plus de
mobilité. Or, quand on laisse se
constituer les héritages, quand euh et
bien le capitalisme se fige, il se
bloque, il il se met à constituer
d'énormes masses euh de richesse figées.
Il y a plus d'innovation, ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui gagnent, la
compétition n'est jamais relancée. Donc
il y a pas cette compétition mobile
théorisée ensuite par le néolibéralisme.
Elle n'est plus possible si vous voulez.
Donc le néolibéralisme va penser les
conditions pour qu'une pour qu'une pour
que la compétition ait lieu partout à
tous les étages de la société tout le
temps et que les riches par exemple
rejouent sans cesse leur richesse. Et
l'idée c'est que c'est c'est modèle du
sport de la compétition sportive
fairplay avec arbitre, règle, loyauté et
cetera, c'est que cette compétition soit
sans cesse relancée. Donc
la théorie du ruissellement qui
consisterait à dire laissons les
monopoles s'accumuler,
favorisons les grandes la constitution
de grande richesse en France et ça
ruissellera
mécaniquement vers les plus démunis.
C'est précisément ce qu'on réfuté les
les néolibéraux. Donc voyez dans la
pensée enfin la pensée dans l'esprit
même de quelqu'un comme Emmanuel Macron
se mélange très confusément des éléments
néolibéraux.
et des éléments ultralibéraux. Pour vous
donner un seul exemple, et dans les
gouvernements qu'on a eu sous nos yeux
depuis des décennies, on a à la fois ce
bon vieil ultralibéralisme toujours là
avec la tentation de la dérégulation,
avec l'accompagnement et exalté de la
financiarisation. On a en même temps
chez les mêmes la critique de tout ça
néolibérale et euh l'enrobage de la
social-démocratie qui sert un peu de
papier cadeau pour avaler enfin tout ça
n'est pas conscient ni délibéré mais
c'est un peu ce qui se passe. Donc on a
trois continents qui s'hybrident euh
dans les mêmes gouvernements
ultralibéralistes, néolibéralisme,
social-démocratie qui est encore autre
chose. Et il faut même ajouter 4e
continent libéralisme classique. Donc ça
fait beaucoup.
Alors autre question internet. Est-ce
que la destruction des identités
connues, communes sexuelles, familial,
religion est une manière d'affaiblir les
masses ?
La destruction des identités.
Est-ce que la destruction des identités
communes, sexuelles, famille, religion
est une manière d'affaiblir les masses ?
Je comprends pas très bien cette
question. [grognement] Euh
c'est c'est lu brut, hein. C'est ce qui
arrive sur mon écran. affaiblir les
masses. Qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire par
affaiblir les masses ?
Euh
les masses sont faibles de toute façon.
La masse c'est l'impotence quoi. C'est
pas s'informe.
Elle s'est informe, c'est amorphe. Donc
dans le vocabulaire dans le Lipman,
c'est euh
c'est pas quelque chose de puissant. Ça
n'est puissant que si il y a une
puissance de la masse uniquement si elle
est formée reprise en main. Et donc je
je j'en viens à la question suivante.
Est-ce que les gilets jaunes démontrent
une certaine capacité à sortir du
consentement ?
Pour moi, c'est évident. Les gilets
jaunes, ce mouvement, c'est un symptôme
de la crise du consentement dont on
parlait tout à l'heure. C'est d'autant
plus évident, je veux pas me livrer à la
sociologie sauvage, je suis pas
sociologue et on n pas encore fait la
sociologie ni l'histoire de ce
mouvement, mais ça te paraît évident. on
a quand même le droit d'avoir des
intuitions. Euh, il paraît évident que
la grande majorité de euh ce la grande
majorité de de ceux qui ont revêtu ce
gilet jaune et cetera et qui ont lancé
ce mouvement étaient des gens qui
pendant des années avaient consenti,
avaient tenté de ça a été dit par des
commentateurs, chroniqueurs et cetera.
Je pense que c'est juste avait tenté de
jouer le jeu de la mondialisation, de
jouer le jeu euh de de tout ce de tout
ce modèle de de société. Pendant très
longtemps, ils ont été dans le
consentement et puis petit à petit, ce
consentement a commencé à affaiblir
depuis longtemps et de plus en plus et
puis et puis au bout d'un moment, ça
fonctionne plus.
Autre question internet. Est-ce que
alors la philosophie anarchiste qui
prône l'émancipation de l'individu au
sein d'un groupe avec la conscience du
groupe est-elle la meilleure manière de
contrer le libéralisme ?
La philosophie anarchiste qui
la philosophie alors je reprends la
question la philosophie anarchiste qui
prône l'émancipation de l'individu au
sein du groupe avec la conscience du
groupe est-elle la meilleure manière de
contrer le libéralisme ?
Alors l'émancipation de l'individu, vous
serez d'accord sur le fait que ça n'a
rien spécifiquement anarchiste ?
C'est euh c'est foncé central dans les
lumières qui n'ont rien d'anarchiste.
Euh c'est central dans le libéralisme.
Quand on pense que il est fondamental
pour chaque individu de pouvoir
s'émanciper quelque part on est libéral.
C'est euh ce qu'il y a de beau dans le
libéralisme et c'est en en c'est ce en
quoi c'est difficile de de se dire
antilibéral. Donc pour moi, ça n'est pas
un marqueur de l'anarchisme du tout. Euh
et ensuite l'idée qu'on ne puisse
s'émanciper comme individu que par et
avec que en relation avec un groupe, ça
n'a rien non plus de spécifiquement
anarchiste. Euh voilà, donc si vous
voulez, je vois pas en quoi c'est
spécifique à à l'anarchisme. Par contre,
la question de fond qui est posée ici,
c'est de savoir si euh la voix pour
défaire le le la domination du
néolibéralisme, c'est ou non l'anarchie.
Et je vous avoue très honnêtement que
[grognement] euh je reste très sceptique
euh sur l'idée même de de l'idée même
euh d'une voix anarchiste pour s'en
sortir. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
anarchiste ?
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire s'en sortir ?
Alors, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire déjà
anarchiste ? Anarchiste, ça veut dire
sortir de des rapports de pouvoir. Si on
le prend de manière très littérale,
étymologique, arqué en grec, ça veut
dire pouvoir. Voilà.
Euh je semble difficile
de
de sortir de cela, de sortir des
rapports de pouvoir.
C'est formidable.
Je vois pas de d'issue, je vois pas de
possibilité de sortir du pouvoir. On est
immergé dans des rapports de pouvoir. Ça
peut devenir une catastrophe mais c'est
pas forcément si grave que ça. On peut
en faire quelque chose. Le pouvoir n'est
pas en soi pour moi la chose à abattre.
Bon, on va sortir de cette discussion
très policée. Vous voyez la France
comment d'ici 3 4 ans vous voyez comment
la le la population réagir ? Est-ce que
vous attendez à des révoltes ? Est-ce
que vous attendez à un pouvoir politique
qui va se durcir comme ça pu être écrit
? Est-ce que c'est cousu de fil blanc
qui vous dire
est-ce que
est-ce que vous votez ?
Oui, ça m'arrive. Ouai.
Et vous votez quoi ?
Euh, ça dépend, je change. Je vote pas
toujours pour la même chose.
Est-ce que vous êtes Est-ce que vous
faites partie des castors qui font bar ?
Attendez, parce qu'il y avait une
première question là.
Ouais, mais c'est fait exprès ça.
Ah d'accord. Ah, vous vous faites ça à
un moment. D'accord. Je vais pas me
laisser faire.
Alors, continuez.
[rires]
[souffle coupé]
Donc je choisis en fait dans votre
rafale de question.
Alors je n'ai pas beaucoup de talent
prophétique.
Donc je suis absolument incapable de
vous dire en France dans 4 ans, c'est ça
qui va se passer.
J'ai pas d'intuition.
Ah par contre si c'est exactement ce que
j'allais vous dire. Par contre j'ai des
intuitions et [grognement] souvent saur
pas si fausse. Donc évidemment ça va
être un peu déceptif. Je suis désolée.
Je vois et je et ça n'a rien plus.
Maintenant, c'est c'est sorti au grand
jour, donc c'est pas compliqué. Je vois
la la
je vois la suite des tendances nouvelles
qui se sont affirmées là. En gros, crise
du consentement, ça ne va pas
s'arranger.
Euh crise du néolibéralisme, je pense
que ça ne va pas cesser de se défaire.
En d'autres termes, le livre que j'ai
écrit au moment où je l'ai écrit, je me
suis dit qu'il était en voie de devenir
complètement obsolète.
le il faut s'adapter puisqu'en fait
j'écrivais sur une hégémonie qui était
déjà en
complètement en crise déliquence
totalement déliquante et en même temps
bien bien pleine de vitalité évidemment
puisqueon on en voit encore les effets
euh dans la réalité et donc je vois la
suite de ça je ne vois pas très bien
comment comment le néolibéralisme
pourrait s'en s'en s'en remettre il a
compris que son unique possibilité
c'est de s'emparer
de l'environnement de la question
environnementale pour inventer une
écologie néolibérale. Mais là, je lui
souhaite bon courage. Je lui souhaite
bon courage parce qu'en fait la dans la
matrice du néolibéralisme, l'idée c'est
la mondialisation.
Donc c'est pour être parlé de manière
très prosaïque par exemple
l'accélération des échanges marchant à
l'échelle mondiale. Donc c'est
nécessairement
en contradiction avec les questions
d'écologie frontale. Je ne vois pas par
quelle magie ils vont pouvoir inventer
[grognement] euh une porte de sortie par
rapport à cette contradiction massive.
Mais en tout cas c'est de c'est de ça
dont ils s'occupent actuellement. Ils
l'ont parfaitement compris. Ils se sont
emparés de l'éducation, de la santé.
La santé, la santé d'ailleurs euh ça
marche plus ou moins bien. Mais quand on
couple la santé à l'écologie, quand on
pense l'écologie, au sens très large du
mot, pas seulement la planète va mal,
mais nos corps vivants ont des troubles
somatiques et psychiques liés à ce monde
nouveau, ce dont on parlait au début de
notre discussion. On se rend compte
qu'il y a il y a quand même échec. Vous
parliez des psychotropes. Bon, il y a un
moment les psychotropes pour s'adapter,
ça fait
ça fait marcher jusqu'à un certain
point. Et puis à un moment ça devient un
problème de santé publique. Bon donc là
moi je je ne vois pas après je n'ai pas
de capacité de à deviner l'avenir mais
je je vois difficilement comment les
néolibéraux vont s'en sortir pour se se
refonder sur une base écologique
pour se sortir du déni
pour voilà ça va être très compliqué.
Donc déjà je vois la suite de cette de
cette crise de l'hégémonie néolibérale
d'une part. D'autre part, ce que je
vois, c'est des publics qui euh se
lèvent un peu partout dans le monde, des
publics euh qui se qui s'identifient et
qui déjouent la conception lipmanienne
de la masse qui nous disait qu'on avait
à faire qu'à des atomes, qu'à des atomes
uniquement préoccupés par trois choses,
à savoir travailler, produire.
euh se divertir, c'est-à-dire
reconstituer sa force de travail par le
loisir, la consommation et cetera et se
reproduire avec les enfants. Donc il
explique, l'Américain normal s'intéresse
à son travail, à sa famille, à son
automobile et c'est tout à fait normal
qu' qu'il ne soit pas capable ni disposé
à s'intéresser au grands problèmes de
l'Amérique et du monde. et qu'il demande
donc il délègue à d'autres experts et
leaders le soin de l'emmener dans la
bonne direction. Ça c'est ce qu'on
disait et c'est ce qu'on disait jusqu'à
il y a très peu de temps. C'est ce que
le discours dominant disait jusqu'à très
peu de temps. Par exemple quand on
entendait les chroniqueurs parler de
l'opinion publique française. Mais ça ça
n'intéresse pas les Français hein. Les
Français ce qu'ils veulent pouvoir
remplir leur cadit, pouvoir avoir un
emploi hein. C'était le discours
dominant. Pouvoir avoir une famille,
fonder une famille, accéder à une maison
et cetera. Ça c'était c'est ce discours
tout le monde aujourd'hui euh est bien
obligé de reconnaître que en réité c'est
c'est un contresens parce que ce que les
soi-disants masses euh lipmaniennes euh
recellèent, c'est aussi des potentialit
ce sont des potentialités que Lipman
refusait de voir et c'est ce que lui a
opposé son grand contradicteur
philosophe John Dey c'est qu'à
l'intérieur de ces grandes masses
modernes, il y a autre chose que des
masses et il y a autre chose que des
atomes. Il y a ce que Ji appelle des
publics, c'est-à-dire des individus qui
ne se sentent pas bien pour une raison
ou pour une autre, qui ont un problème,
des problème,
qui font de la philosophie,
pas forcément. On fait pas de la
philosophie quand on voit pas bien.
Alors ça c'est une autre question et qui
donc sur la base de leur problème se
s'identifie identifie que d'autres ont
le même type de problème. À partir de là
il y a donc la possibilité d'émergence
de ce qu'il appelle des publics. Et pour
DIY qui va contredire l'ipman
systématiquement pendant 25 ans, un peu
moins pendant 20 ans sur tous les gestes
théoriques politique de Lipman. Ce qu'il
faut faire, c'est oui, on part des
masses, on voit ces potentialités
embryonnaires des publics et ce qu'il
faut, c'est refonder nos démocraties sur
ces publics. C'est-à-dire le but, c'est
que l'État soit au service de ses
publics. Les publics, contrairement à la
masse apathique de Lipman, ils se
sentent même parce qu'ils sentent qu'ils
ont un problème commun.
ayant un problème commun, ils se mettent
en mouvement, ils sont pas passifs, ils
deviennent actifs et ils cherchent une
thérapeutique par rapport à leurs
problèmes. Et à partir de là, ils ont
une capacité grâce aux médias, aux
moyens de communication dit du qui sont
essentiels pour lui. Ils ont des moyens
de s'identifier, de se connecter entre
eux et d'aller chercher des ressources
dans ce que du OIi appelle le savoir, la
science, la connaissance pour et donc
faire appel à à de l'expertise pour
envisager de manière expérimentale des
solutions.
Bienvenue sur internet.
Alors effectivement, c'est l'un des sens
d'internet et c'est ce qui explique par
exemple que les patients dans les
hôpitaux ont totalement changé.
Les jeunes générations actuelles qui ont
20 ou 30 ans sont totalement différents.
Moi je je sais puisque j'ai commencé à
enseigner euh je il y a 25 ans, j'avais
pas du tout le même type de
en 1971.
Ouais. J'avais pas du tout le même type
d'étudiant. J'avais des étudiants très
sympathiques. J'en ai un excellent
souvenir mais qui étaient assez passif
collectivement.
Dépolitisé. Il il se disait d'ailleurs à
l'époque à politique quand moi-même
j'avais 20 ans, on avait le même
discours et puis petit à petit les
choses ont changé. C'est-à-dire que
petit à petit, j'ai vu une nouvelle
génération émerger euh voilà, c'est ces
âges-là de gens qui sont en voie de
politisation très très impressionnante,
sont extrêmement actifs, sont très au
courant de plein de choses, vont
chercher du savoir pour s'outiller,
s'armer, s'organiser [grognement]
collectivement pour lutter contre des
choses. Donc voilà, il y a des
communautés qui se constituent, il y a
des [grognement] communautés de savoir,
de pratique, de d'expérimentation qui se
constituent, ce que je trouve
parfaitement réjouissant et pour moi,
c'est une des tendances qui ne va pas
cesser de se développer. Même chose pour
les patients. Les patients qui étaient
finalement ben une dame ou un monsieur
tout seul devant un grand médecin, ça
c'est fini. De plus en plus, on a
affaire à des gens qui sont qui se
connectent les uns aux autres, qui
s'associent à la grande rupture dans
l'histoire de la santé, c'est le sida,
hein, où euh gros immense échec de la
médecine avec le VIH et constitution de
communautés pour des raisons évidemment
sociologiques autres liées à au public
impacté par le sida. constitution de
communautés très actives qui se sont euh
politisées, qui ont euh [grognement] euh
qui sont qui ont imposé ce qu'on appelle
en France la démocratie sanitaire,
c'est-à-dire que les décisions de santé
publique doivent se prendre avec les
publics de de malades.
Voilà, ça c'est tout à fait la même
chose et ça illustre bien ce que DUI
appelle euh les publics qui déjouent
donc le diagnostic lipmanien sur les
masses. Donc du il va reprendre toutes
les déterminations listées par Lipman
sur ce qu'est une masse en disant oui,
on a affaire à ça mais en disant qu'on a
aussi affaire à d'autres potentialités
grâce aux nouvelles technologies et
cetera et cetera, grâce à la société
industrielle elle-même d'ailleurs et au
savoir spécialisé expérimental qui est
la science contemporaine.
Revenons à notre parenthèse de
futurologie. H
donc là on a vu les mouvements
contestataires, vous les anticipez un
peu comme nous, c'est-à-dire
ils existent déjà. Oui, mais là c'est
simplement le petit canarie dans la
mine.
Comment vous modélisez ou comment vous
anticipez la réaction du pouvoir et
comment vous anticipez la réaction du
pouvoir néolibéral ? Est-ce qu'il va se
tendre, se rédire, devenir violent ?
H on le voit déjà.
On le voit déjà. Oui. Mais ça c'est un
échec parce que dans la théorie
libanienne, le but est d'éviter la
violence. à partir du moment où un
gouvernement néolibéral commence à
sortir les matraques, c'est qu'il a
échoué.
Le but le but c'est de fabriquer le
consentement. Donc c'est d'avoir un
consentement. C'est que ça se fasse avec
le consentement. Quand on passe à la
violence, on passe à autre chose.
Qui est
alors qui est qui est qui est qui est
rien de théorique, qui est de la pure
brutalité politique de de d'un mouvement
hégémonique qui a été hégémonique et qui
fonctionne plus.
On assiste au dernier
c'est absolument pas théorisé. C'est
absolument pas théorisé.
Oh, on va on va le théoriser le le Bon,
allez, question internet. Est-ce que le
consentement va bientôt faire place à la
contrainte ? Bon, on vient d'en parler.
H
euh à entendre les néolibérales, les
néolibéralistes. Euh,
néolibéraux [raclement de gorge] ?
Ouais, merci. Euh, désolé, je
Donc, il y a longtemps, les néolibéraux,
ils œuvrent pour la paix mondiale.
Pourtant, leur doctrine semble créer
beaucoup de guér et de conflits.
Oui, c'est tout à fait ça.
Effectivement, le le l'agenda
fondamental du néolibéralisme, c'est une
grande paix mondiale.
La guerre est un archaïme.
Euh, jamais fait autant de guerre, hein.
Comment
on a jamais fait autant de guerre.
Oui, mais encore une fois, je vous ai
dit, nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
l'avocé. ou oui mais je vous ai dit et
c'est très important nous ne sommes pas
dans un monde intégralement néolibéral.
Nous sommes dans un monde en partie
néolibérale, un néolibéralisme qui
échoue très largement très largement
également ultralibéral, ce qui est
encore autre chose. Enfin tout ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure. Donc le le
néolibéralisme
est à la fois hégémonique et en même
temps parfaitement limité dans sa
puissance.
Alors question pas trop mal. Pensez-vous
qu'il faudrait enseigner la philosophie
plus tôt dans le cursus scolaire ?
Avez-vous déjà vu des ateliers de philo
pour les enfants en primaire par exemple
?
C'est une question extrêmement
difficile.
L'éducation,
c'est une question extrêmement
difficile. Alors moi, je suis très
partagée là-dessus. Euh à la fois, je ne
sais toujours pas ce que je pense sur
cette question. Je suis vraiment très
partagée et peut-être que la seule
manière pour moi de trancher sera
d'expérimenter quelque chose. Sauf que
c'est très difficile de faire des
expémentation sur des enfants.
Bon, en même temps, on en fait tous
puisque quand on a des enfants, on fait
des expérimentations sur bon. Donc on
peut se consoler comme ça. Mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi c'est compliqué. Non,
mais je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
compliqué. C'est une question que je me
pose depuis très très longtemps. D'un
certain point de vue, on peut se dire
faire de la philosophie avec des
enfants, c'est ça qu'il faut faire
puisqu'en fait les enfants sont
naturellement philosophes.
Voilà. Puis a un moment où ils
s'arrêtent, ils sont beaucoup moins
philosophes, ils ont plus de mal à faire
de la philosophie, les choses se
durcissent, saucifient et c'est plus
compliqué. Les enfants aiment le
questionnement.
En même temps, ce qui est difficile avec
la manière dont moi je pratique la
philosophie, c'est que c'est une
discipline
avec vos enfants.
Non, je je pratique pas la philosophie
avec mes enfants. Euh la manière dont je
pratique la philosophie avec mes
étudiants où j'ai pu le faire avec mes
élèves, je dire les plus jeunes avec
lesquels j'ai fait de la philosophie,
ils avaient au minimum 17 ans quoi.
C'est une manière un peu dure.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas non plus
qu'une partie de plaisir. C'est-à-dire
que pour moi, pour que pour par exemple
pour construire un problème
philosophique,
il faut rentrer dans des choses
négatives, faire mal.
Il faut se faire mal. C'est quand même
angoissant. On a aucune réponse et il
faut qu'on qu'on rentre dans quelque
chose on a aucune réponse. C'est très
anxiogène et il faut le supporter. Il
faut supporter ça à un certain temps
pour vraiment trouver la question. C'est
pas facile quand on est en vie. on a
besoin de trouver des solutions et on n
pas forcément envie d'approfondir des
questions. Voilà, c'est difficile, c'est
pas naturel, c'est une c'est une
attitude c'est une attitude
antinaturelle. Et en plus la manière
dont je fais de la philosophie, c'est
pour moi la philosophie c'est pas la
pensée. La pensée c'est beaucoup plus
large. La philosophie c'est une manière
de penser parmi d'autres qui a été
inventée en Grèce euh qui a qui par
ailleurs est une tradition. C'est-à-dire
que euh la philosophie, c'est pas la
pensée, c'est une certaine tradition de
pensée qui passe par de la transmission
de de philosophe en philosophe. Donc il
y a des filiations généalogiques un peu
comme dans des familles par exemple
Nietzsche et Éite de Kant et cetera et
cetera et beaucoup moins de tel autre.
Voyez c'est bon. Et que du même coup
faire de la philosophie sans auteur,
sans rapport à la tradition me paraît
compliqué. C'est-à-dire que quand moi je
fais de la philosophie avec des
débutants, je leur donne
c'estes euh je leur transmets cet
héritage et c'est compliqué de le faire
avec un enfant très jeune. Voilà. Donc
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que
[grognement] à la fois je me dis c'est
très difficile
voir dangereux de faire de la
philosophie avec des enfants et en même
temps je me dis c'est ce que John Dey
pense fondamentalement qu'il faut faire
de la philosophie avec des enfants par
exemple. C'est pour lui c'est
fondamental. conseille un très bon
bouquin qui s'appelle de l'éducation de
Krishna Murti.
H
euh c'est pas mal. Autre question
d'internet, quels sont les philosophe
français contemporains qui vous
intéresse ?
Euh bah alors celui qui m'a beaucoup
beaucoup aidé là récemment, c'est alors
il est mort mais il y a peu de temps,
c'est Michel Fouco qui est vraiment euh
chez qui j'ai trouvé beaucoup de choses
à la fois pour m'aider à penser tout ce
qui concerne le rapport au patient, à la
santé, à la maladie, tout le travail que
je fais avec autour des hôpitaux, autour
des réformes néolibérales, de
des soins palliatifs, de la monétisation
de la mort,
toutes ces questionsl parce que en fait
je suis responsable d'un d'un master qui
s'appelle soin éthique et santé. euh
dans lequel j'ai des étudiants qui sont
en fait euh des infirmiers, des
médecins, des paramédicaux. Euh faire
mal.
Oui. Et c'est c'est vraiment difficile
euh de de les de voir à quoi ils sont
exposés. Et donc alors moi je n'y suis
pas exposée en première personne, je
sais pas si j'aurai les nerfs mais j'en
reçois je reçois quand même un peu un
petit quelque chose de ce à quoi ils
sont exposés. Et Michel Fouco nous a
aidé pendant des années à faire nos
séminaires de master. avec ce ces
étudiants et à réfléchir sur les
mutations du système sanitaire actuel.
Et puis euh c'est chez Michel Fouco que
j'ai trouvé la piste Lipman parce qu'en
fait Michel Fouco a fait un cours
absolument génial à la fin des années 70
au collège de France. Un cours qui avait
un succès fou.
Vraiment un cours très très
impressionnant. Il en a fait plein des
des beaux cours. Mais alors là vraiment
c'est très impressionnant parce qu'en
fait il voit les premiers néolibéraux
arriver au pouvoir.
Donc euh pour vous donner des noms,
Rean, sauf que Rean, c'est plutôt de
l'ultralibéralisme et pas du
néolibéralisme. Margarette Toucher qui
est un mélange de d'ultralibéralisme à
la Herbert Spencer brutal et cetera et
de néolibéralisme à la Friedrichek avec
le rôle de l'État, du droit, des règles
du jeu. D'accord. Et puis celui qui est
le plus chimiquement pur, c'est chez
nous, c'est Valérie Giscardestin. et il
voit arriver donc le néolibéralisme
prendre le pouvoir et de manière mais
vraiment saisissante en très peu de
temps, il trouve le texte un
Strasbourgeois qui s'appelle Biger qui
lit de très très près et il voit que
l'ordolibéralisme allemand, c'est-à-dire
la la variante allemande du
néolibéralisme a un rôle central dans la
construction européenne
et il se dit que ça c'est un nouveau
libéralisme qui n'est pas le libéralisme
classique. Donc il va aller lire tout ça
et il va découvrir que Lipman est un
auteur central puisqu'il y a eu un
colloque qui s'est tenu en en 1938 à
Paris qui s'est appelé le colloc Lipman
où tous les libéraux affolés par le
désastre de la crise de 29, affolé par
la manière dont le libéralisme classique
avait failli, le capitalisme sauvage
avait tout détruit, se sont réunis donc
en 38 à Paris en août 38 autour de
l'œuvre de Walter Lipman pour refonder
repenser
complètement à nouveau frais le
libéralisme. Ce qu'ils ont fait avec des
ruptures vraiment spectaculaires, retour
de l'État, transformer l'espèce humaine
au lieu de la laisser faire comme elle
envie. Il faut plus faire confiance à
l'espèce humaine parce qu'elle est
déficiente, donc il faut la modeler, la
transformer et cetera. Sauf que Fouco
n'a pas lu Libman en réalité vraiment.
Il a dû feuilleter le livre The Good
Society, mais je crois qu'il l'a pas lu
parce qu'il n'a pas vu tout cet
arrière-plan biologique darwinien.
Euh donc c'est Fouo qui m'a mis sur la
voix de de de Lipman, mais c'est en
entrant dans la dans le texte de Lipman
notamment grâce à c'est Christian Laval
et Pierre Dardau qui ont fait un texte
très intéressant sur le néolibéralisme
qui m'avait mis sur la voix en disant
que la le mot clé, c'est ça qui m'a fait
acquérir le livre, le mot clé, il y a
juste une petite phrase dans leur livre
qui s'appelle La nouvelle raison du
monde. Eux c'est des lecteurs de Fouco
et de Secours. [grognement]
Il disait que le mot clé du livre de
Lipman, c'était l'adaptation.
Et là, je me suis dit, je je vais
peut-être trouver ce que je cherche
depuis longtemps à savoir d'où vient
cette injonction politique selon
laquelle il faudrait s'adapter. Nous
serions toujours en retard. Il faudrait
réadapter les populations au nouvel
environnement et cetera et cetera.
Vous avez pas lu Krishna Murti ? Non
mais il y a plein de choses que j'ai pas
lu. Il y a vraiment vraiment plein de
choses. [rires]
Bon, on arrive pratiquement à la fin de
notre interview. Est-ce que vous voulez
pas qu'on parle quel de quelque chose en
particulier ? Vous avez
Ah non, moi j'aime bien vos propositions
de discussion, moi ça me va.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
nous conseiller
là ? Brûle pour poid. Non, j'ai pas
d'idée.
Ah bah, il va falloir chercher.
Ben, je viens de vous en donner. Le
naissance de la biopolitique, c'est le
cours de Fouca pour ceux qui
s'intéressent au néolibéralisme, ceux
qui n'en auraient pas marre, euh qui ne
seraient pas lassés de l'histoire du
néolibéralisme. Donc il faut aller voir
ce cours, il est vraiment bien. Ça
s'appelle naissance de la biopolitique.
Alors attention, ils seront peut-être
déçus parce que euh en fait ça parle pas
beaucoup de biopolitique.
Pas de spoil hein.
Non mais il il parle pas en fait
beaucoup de biopolitique. il en parle un
tout petit peu puis après il passe au
néolibéralisme
justement justement et justement c'est
précisément ça c'est que moi j'ai
j'étais là ah ça va être formidable il
va parler du politique et du biologique
et en fait quand il est rentré dans le
néolibéralisme il a dit ce cette chose
qui est fausse qui est que le
néolibéralisme c'est la rupture avec le
naturalisme.
Et en fait quand je suis allé voir
Libman c'était absolument pas la rupture
avec le naturalisme c'était un un
nouveau naturalisme libéral. Bon, donc
ça c'est un premier premier une première
piste de de de lecture.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur les
réseaux ?
Oui. Alors, je je suis pas très doué en
slogan, mais non, moi je je je n'ai
aucun conseil à leur donner. euh juste
continuer à faire ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure, c'est-à-dire s'emparer euh des
outils technologiques, des réseaux
sociaux euh pour euh connecter euh faire
des communautés, des publics,
des souff une souffrance sociale, des
problèmes politiques, des experts en
sciences qu'on que loin d'écouter comme
nous donnons la direction, un expert est
incapable de donner une direction. un
expert, il connaît un tout petit morceau
de quelque chose. Il est pas capable de
donner la direction loin d'écouter les
experts, les mettre à notre à leur
service à ces ces jeunes générations
pour leur dire ben vous expert, vous
devez travailler là-dessus. C'est ça
qu'on veut. On doit donner en fait la la
la feuille de route sur les non pas le
but ultime de l'histoire parce qu'il y
en a pas mais sur les problèmes à
traiter. Et je crois qu'il faut que les
jeunes générations continuent. Elles
sont déjà en train de le faire donc je
n'ai pas de conseil à leur donner mais
il faut qu'elles continuent.
Barbara Sigler, merci. Vous en prie.
Merci à vous.
[musique]